ils sont motivés pour gagner cette
première édition
stéphane foncé ses deux enfants
profitent d'une matinée dominicale
ensoleillée pour se lancer dans la
compétition
il commence à installer leurs
décorations de noël j'installe les
premières qui sont au fait qu'ils sont
déjà pré installée puisque je laisse les
vices à l'année et du coulage installe
la partie façon charlene est enneigée je
l'aide à par exemple à monter les
décorations sur le toit quand on fait
des décorations prête des sapins ou des
choses comme ça on je l'aide à les
installer je devais d'aller tester des
choses comme ça les décorations qu'on va
mettre
j'adore parce qu'une maison sera
toujours lui parce que moi j'adore les
décorations
c'est monte et après que je suis sûr
qu'on va gagner et pour tenter de
remporter le concours stéphane a
renforcé ses illuminations les
nouveautés un bonhomme de neige lumineux
et une guirlande pour napper le toit un
rituel annuel à c'est l'aspect fait
l'aspect festif et puis comme j'ai des
retours positifs de tout le voisinage
pour concernant ces décorations comme
quoi ça
un enchantement bah voilà ça ça me fait
plaisir
un enchantement qui touche même les
adversaires directs de stephen à whitera
redoutable d'habitude tout dix ans on
s'est un peu la guerre pour la
décoration de noël
sauf que cette année et je n'aurai pas
le temps d'en faire donc donc il sera
largement devant moi je fais toujours
des belles décorations des belles
innovations c'est voilà ont tous les ans
les attend avec impatience et décoration
et lorsque le test lumière est effectuée
tout semble fonctionner la famille fonds
séparé pour le passage du jury prévue le
18 décembre prochain